in 1965 a young caltech graduate student
by the name of gary flandro
was poring over his notes in building
180 of the jet propulsion laboratory
studying the intricacies of using
planets gravitational fields
to slingshot spacecraft into the outer
reaches of space
with no need for additional propellant
the gravity assist
a method of propulsion that uses the
gravity of a gravitational body
to literally pull the spacecraft into a
new trajectory
and velocity as he examined the possible
trajectories
gary noticed something incredible in the
late 70s a window would open up
where the alignment of the planets would
allow for a single satellite
to pinball its way between jupiter
saturn
uranus and neptune before eventually
being spit out
to the outer reaches of our solar system
and beyond
with this knowledge a flurry of activity
began within nasa and jpl
a once in a lifetime opportunity had
been found
that would not come about again for
another 175 years
and it was imperative that the
opportunity was not squandered
planning began and in 1977 two
satellites
voyager 1 and 2 would launch a board
that three-staged
titan 3e rocket voyager 2 would utilize
a gravity assist
with jupiter saturn and uranus before
racing by neptune
before it eventually exited the solar
system
while voyager 1 completed a more direct
path
whipping by jupiter and saturn before
venturing into deep space
moving away from earth faster than any
other spacecraft
voyager 1 is now over 22.8
billion kilometers away from earth
that's so far away
that voyager 1 is now outside the
influence of the sun's
constant stream of solar wind meaning it
is now
in interstellar space officially
reaching the region in august
2012. we as a species
have now left our mark in interstellar
space after a 35 year long journey
a ponderously long time in the scale of
human life
and that was with the help of multiple
gravity assists
while we can build and deploy these
technical marvels
to investigate other worlds sending
ourselves into space
is another thing entirely and using
gravity assists
to visit our closest neighbours makes
little sense
to date the furthest humans have
ventured into space
is to the dark side of the moon a mere
400 000 kilometers away
if our ambitions to create colonies on
mars
are to be realized humans are going to
need a spacecraft that are faster
and more efficient than the ones we
currently have at our disposal
mars is on average about 64 million
kilometers away
the fastest and most efficient method we
have to reach mars
using the homan transfer method with
launch windows
every 26 months takes about 9 months to
complete
faster transfer times are possible but
engineers are stuck in a catch-22
it takes fuel not only to accelerate the
spacecraft but to decelerate it too
there are no disc breaks in space the
more we accelerate
the more we have to decelerate too in
order to carry all that
additional propellant engineers will be
forced to sacrifice
payload waste reducing the space
available for food
water and other vital supplies for a
crude mission to mars
we can take some solace in the fact
faster transfer times
will reduce the supplies needed and will
reduce the crew's exposure to the high
radiation of space
but what if we could achieve faster
transfer times
without sacrificing payload what if we
could achieve
faster transfer times with even more
payload
let's first examine current technology
to see where things could be
improved the atlas v rocket that brought
perseverance to mars
utilized chemical combustion to propel
itself
a method where a fuel and an oxidizer
are combined in a combustion chamber
and ignited the resulting exothermic
reaction
causes the combustion products to
rapidly heat up and expand
the nozzle design then directs the
expanding gas
in one direction to achieve thrust
getting the most out of our fuel
and oxidizer is the first step to
maximizing our thrust per unit weight of
fuel
there is a useful quantity engineers use
to describe
this property of fuels and oxidizers
specific impulse
we described in detail what this value
represents in our last video
on the x15 explaining how it represents
the total energy we can extract
from our propellants per unit weight in
that video
we used this equation where specific
impulse is defined
by thrust force divided by fuel flow
rates
this is an extremely important metric
for our mars transfer vehicle
the higher we can push our specific
impulse
the less fuel we need to bring which
frees up space
for payload or we can bring the same
amount of fuel
and increase our velocity to reach mars
sooner
or even be able to leave outside that
ideal
home and transfer window so how do we
improve
specific impulse the technology with the
best specific impulse currently
is ion propulsion take the enstar ion
drive
aboard the now retired dawn spacecraft
this engine used electric power to
propel ions
and achieve astronomical specific
impulses
the engine releases xenon atoms into an
ionization chamber
and then bombards them with high energy
electrons
the collisions produce a positive xenon
atom
and more electrons these electrons are
then collected by a positively charged
chamber wall while the positive xenon
atoms migrate towards the chamber exit
which contains two grits a positive grid
called the screen grid and a negative
grid called the accelerator grid
the high electrical potential between
these grids
causes the positive ions to accelerate
and shoot out of the engine at speeds of
up to 40 kilometers per second which is
vastly higher than what chemical
combustion can provide
which has a typical exhaust velocity of
about three to four kilometers per
second
this exhaust velocity is paramount to
achieving
higher specific impulses if we play
around with the specific impulse
equation
we can see why specific impulse equals
the thrust force divided by fuel flow
rate
thrust force is equal to the mass flow
rate times the velocity
while the fuel flow rate is the weight
of the fuel on earth
and thus this value changes to mass flow
rate
times acceleration due to gravity and as
we see
the mass flow rates cancel themselves
out leaving us with only exhaust
velocity
divided by gravity so it's rather
obvious
to maximize specific impulse we need to
maximize exhaust velocity
and ion propulsion is the best
technology
we have to do that right now with 10
times the exhaust velocity
the ion drive can achieve 10 times the
specific impulse
that's a phenomenal increase so why
aren't we using this technology for
interplanetary missions
mass flow rate may not be important to
specific impulse
but it is massively important to thrust
as we saw just now
thrust force is equal to mass flow rate
times the velocity
chemical combustion happens extremely
quickly
it is after all a controlled explosion
and so it is capable of accelerating
millions
upon millions of molecules out in a very
short space of time
leading to a high mass flow rate high
thrust is very important for particular
maneuvers
like capture burns where a rocket will
fire to slow its speed down
enough to be captured by a planet's
gravity the window for this deceleration
may only be a few hours where iron
propulsion
simply cannot provide enough thrust in a
short enough time
to successfully complete the maneuver
ion propulsion
simply does not have the mass flow rate
necessary to achieve
high thrust it took the dawn spacecraft
four days to change its velocity by just
94 kilometers per hour to increase our
ability to change velocity quickly
we need to increase the mass flow rate
to do this
we need to increase our input power for
ion propulsion
that power comes in the form of
electricity which provides the energy to
ionize our propellant
and accelerate it using an electric or
magnetic field
current-generation ion-propelled
spacecraft use solar panels to provide
that electricity
the dawn spacecraft has panels capable
of producing
10 kilowatts of power when orbiting
earth
which diminished to 1.3 kilowatts by the
time it reached its destination
in the asteroid belt three times further
away from the sun
scaling that solar power becomes
impractical very quickly
nasa estimates that a mars transport
vehicle would need at least
400 to 2 000 kilowatts of power
to carry astronauts and cargo to and
from mars
so how do we power something like that
nuclear power
is the only thing that can give the
power density needed
to make this viable this isn't a new
concept
in 1961 the atomic energy commission and
nasa
launched the nuclear engine for rocket
vehicle applications program
or nerva for short this program
developed
and ground tested 20 reactors before it
was disbanded
in 1973 due to budget constraints
but was recently revitalized when the us
congress approved
125 million dollars in research funding
for nuclear propulsion there are two
primary types of nuclear space
propulsion
nuclear electric which would power an
ion drive like we saw above
and nuclear thermal which was the focus
of the nirva program
so let's start there nuclear thermal
propulsion works by harnessing the heat
created during nuclear fission to
provide the
energy needed to expand and accelerate a
propellant
through an exhaust nozzle here the
nuclear reactors work in much the same
way as a nuclear reactor here on
earthwood
where a chain reaction of neutrons
colliding with uranium atoms
splits them and creates more neutrons
and a tremendous amount of heat
to capture this heat a propellant
typically liquid hydrogen
is pumped through the reactor core which
will cool the reactor core
and pass the heat to the liquid hydrogen
which rapidly expands
and accelerates out of the thruster
nozzle at high speeds
typically around 8 kilometers per second
twice as fast as chemical combustion
and thus about twice the specific
impulse at around
887 seconds however
it's not all sunshine and rainbows using
hydrogen as a propellant
comes with some issues it can attack the
fuel rods if they are not adequately
protected
with a material that is resistant to
hydrogen's destructive tendencies
liquid hydrogen also has to be stored at
extremely low cryogenic temperatures
and if it is allowed to rise in
temperature it needs to be vented
to prevent an explosion and on top of
this
the tiny molecule is so small it can
slip through
seemingly solid materials as it can fit
between the spaces of larger molecules
this makes it unsuitable for long
storage periods
and ideally we want a mars transfer
vehicle
that can sit in orbit around the earth
or mars
for extended periods waiting for the
crew to arrive and begin its journey
between the planets
then when it arrives the crew descends
in a separate vehicle
leaving the transfer vehicle parked in
orbit once again
liquid hydrogen is just a pain to use in
this application
so why use it because when it comes to
maximizing exhaust velocities
and thus specific impulse low molecular
weight
exhaust products are important assume
for a moment that all the heat energy we
input into
the system is converted to kinetic
energy
in the exhaust products kinetic energy
equals a half times the mass
times the velocity squared to find the
velocity
we can rearrange this equation so now we
see
that velocity equals the square root of
two times the energy divided by the mass
it's clear here that increasing the mass
of the exhaust particles
will decrease the velocity of our
exhaust
hydrogen is the lightest element and
thus maximizes specific impulse
if we were to use another propellant it
would be extremely difficult to make a
nuclear thermal propelled spacecraft
with a high enough specific impulse to
justify its use
the next slightest gas is helium which
is twice as heavy as hydrogen
and thus will reduce our specific
impulse by the square root of two
nearly negating all the advantage
nuclear thermal propulsion can provide
the next slightest element which isn't a
solid at temperatures we require
is nitrogen which is 14 times heavier
and thus
would decrease our specific impulse by
the square root of 14
which is 3.7 times worse making a
nitrogen nuclear thermal engine
worse than a traditional combustion
engine so
we can't get away from this hydrogen
storage problem and if we hope to use
nuclear thermal propulsion
we are going to need to figure out how
to keep hydrogen
cryogenically stored for extended
periods
if this problem could be solved the
higher specific impulse and higher
thrust
could cut our transfer times to mars by
half or
potentially open launch windows outside
of the ideal
home and transfer window so can we get
around
this hydrogen storage problem while
using nuclear power to achieve higher
specific impulses
this is where ion propulsion becomes
really attractive again
one massive advantage in iron
propulsion's favor
is its ability to use heavier inert and
easily storable noble gases
as propellants like xenon or krypton
this goes against our previous
understanding where low exhaust
molecular masses
are beneficial to higher exhaust
velocities
this is possible because we are using
electric power
to launch these atoms at tremendous
speeds
the ion exhaust velocity is defined by
the charge of the ion
the voltage that it has been accelerated
by and the mass of the ion
the charge and mass of the ion are
defined by the propellant choice
but we can scale that voltage very high
before we hit a limit in performance
due to material properties or some other
physical limit
for combustion or nuclear thermal
engines we are converting thermal power
to kinetic energy
that thermal power is difficult to scale
chemical combustion is limited by the
energy we can liberate
from the chemical bonds of the
propellants and by the temperature our
engine can operate at before it melts
this
is a problem for nuclear thermal power
too which has to run
extremely high reactor core temperatures
of 2500 degrees celsius
to achieve exhaust velocities high
enough to justify its use
specialized nuclear fuel designs are
needed to survive these temperatures
and any higher would destroy the reactor
for reference this is an order of
magnitude higher than nuclear reactors
here on earth need to achieve
which typically operate at about 300
degrees celsius
as they are in effect just boiling high
pressure water
ion thrusters do not come close to the
operating temperatures that thermally
driven engines do
and we can crank that voltage up high
enough that the added mass of the ion
barely matters we are still achieving 10
times the specific impulse of
traditional engines
could we use a lighter propellant to
increase specific impulse
of course but the advantages of using
propellants like xenon and krypton
are so good that the drop in exhaust
velocity
and specific impulse are worth it being
a nerd
they can easily be stored over the long
thrust cycles iron propulsion needs
making them the ideal propellant for
long duration
interplanetary missions larger atoms
like xenon
also hold on to the electrons in their
electron cloud
much looser than smaller atoms like
hydrogen
so it takes less energy to ionize xenon
than it takes to ionize hydrogen so this
reduces the electrical power
needed for the first step in our ion
propulsion process
and most critically higher mass exhaust
improves
thrust this equation defines the thrust
an ion propulsion engine can generate
where ion mass forms the denominator of
our specific impulse equation
it forms the numerator for our thrust
equation
meaning an increase in ion mass will
increase our thrust
which is the spec that iron propulsion
struggles with most
a worthy trade-off to use nuclear power
to generate electricity in space
and power our ion drive we will need to
figure out a way to cool the reactor
core for the nuclear thermal engine the
propellant acts as a coolant
for the nuclear electric engine we will
need a closed loop coolant system
where we do not expend the coolant but
keep it in a cycle between the hot
engine
and a heat exchanger the only method we
have to dump heat overboard in space
is through radiative cooling so a
nuclear electric propelled spacecraft
will need massive radiator fins where
this coolant can pass
through this is feasible but we have
a long way to go with developing nuclear
engines
for space and even with this added power
nuclear powered ion propulsion would
still be on the low end of thrust
in all likelihood these ion propelled
engines will need to be a
hybrid engine that can use chemical
combustion for high thrust maneuvers
or if the problem of long-term hydrogen
storage can be addressed
a nuclear hybrid engine is extremely
attractive
where our high thrust burns can be
produced by the nuclear thermal engine
and then through neutron absorbing
control mechanisms
like these rotating drums where one side
is coated in a neutron reflector
and the other is coated in a neutron
absorber
by simply rotating these drums the
engine temperature could be lowered
and switched to a closed-loop coolant
system that could power our
electric generator and provide extremely
high specific impulse
and a gradual increase in velocity that
could drastically cut
our travel times to mars or perhaps
allow humans to venture
even further into our solar system and
begin
our gradual exploration and settlement
of our cosmic neighborhood
this is an incredibly complex topic with
many nuanced and complicated ideas that
i struggled to grasp
until i found the right equations i
struggle to understand how thrust would
require
high mass flow rate yet specific impulse
is much higher
when your exhaust molecular weight is
low the eureka moments
all came from dimensional analysis of
the equations
and their derivations being able to
understand the language of the universe
is a vital tool in decrypting the world
of physics
that's why brilliant is such a great
partner to these videos
brilliant has curated two learning paths
that will be perfect for both newcomers
and experienced learners the first
science foundations
will teach you everything you need to
understand these videos
from chemical reactions to electricity
and magnetism
to classical mechanics and then when you
are ready
you can level up by taking the advanced
and applied science learning path
which will take you through courses on
special relativity
gravitational physics and astronomy
brilliant is the perfect place to hone
your skills
with easy to follow curated courses that
will take you from knowing nothing
to having a well-rounded understanding
of the building blocks of an engineering
career
brilliant's thought-provoking courses
will help you seize them
in a new life they'll guide you from
curiosity to mastery
through storytelling interactive
challenges and problems to solve
you'll start by having fun with their
interactive puzzles and visuals
but with a little bit of persistence and
effort
you'll be amazed at what you can
accomplish if you are naturally curious
want to build your problem-solving
skills want to develop confidence in
your analytical abilities
or like me find fulfillment in continual
lifelong learning
then get brilliant premium to learn
something new
every day if you are looking for
something else to watch right now
why not watch my previous video about
the insane engineering of the fastest
aircraft
in history the x-15 or watch real
science's
latest video about the insane biology of
the hammerhead shark
you